[Music]
five monitors to test including the new
apple studio display all concealed so we
don't know which is which
two sets of eyes one pair belonging to a
professional colorist so this one is a
thumbs up here come the horses good
temporal motion
honestly i feel like i'm at an eye
doctor i have zero idea what this test
does one okay maybe two winning monitors
welcome to monitor madness aka the only
way to determine if apple's new studio
display is worth your hard earned 15.99
ah yes sixteen hundred dollars
sorry i mean 15.99 for a monitor two
years ago i bought this lg monitor for
450
and i thought that was a lot of money
for a monitor but the apple studio
monitor isn't just a boring old computer
monitor it's a smart monitor inside it's
got an a13 bionic chip the same one
that's in the iphone 11. for real that
processor unlocks better video calling
and speaker performance
or at least that's what apple says but
just how good is it and what makes one
monitor more expensive than another
monitor to find out i put the 27-inch
studio display up against four other
monitors
a 5k lg display which has basically the
same specs as the studio and costs 300
less
my own 4k lg monitor and to round out
the comparison a 370 dollar 4k samsung
smart monitor and a professional 4k dell
that costs nearly four thousand dollars
if you want the names and the confusing
model numbers take a screenshot of this
i'm not saying them out loud
here we go
monitor testing
we're actually not going anywhere we're
staying in the studio because mac studio
display and
studio number one display quality
here's the thing about testing this to
my eye displays have gotten so good that
it's actually hard to tell the
difference the best way you can tell the
crispness of this is in ed harris's
wrinkles that's why i brought in someone
with better eyes than me daniel
silverman is a professional colorist he
spends his days color correcting movies
and advertisements so he's a great eye
for this stuff
my producer kenny hid the five different
displays and hooked them up to the new
mac studio desktop which had test files
including 4k videos yes the top gun
trailer and some professional color test
tools
the studio display by the way works with
any newer mac not just this new desktop
yeah the whites look pretty good
grays look pretty good dan and i both
evaluated them on our own so not to
influence each other
out of them all dan liked both the lg
displays the best
specifically the more expensive one all
the first three so far this one seems
pretty good you know there's good detail
there's no clipping there's no crushing
i liked the apple studio and the 5k lg
the best and really struggled to tell
the difference between them
i mean honestly if you told me that this
display and the last one were the same i
kind of would believe you maybe the like
coloring here is a little bit yellower
i need to look at these two side by side
we both noticed a yellowish tint on the
apple display but when we turned off
true tone apple's automatic adjustment
feature any noticeable color
irregularity was gone oh that's it it's
much less yellow it still looks
different but i think the lg is almost
like a touch cooler and you know
honestly like between these two they're
they're pretty excellent looking
monitors so yeah tie on display quality
number two webcam quality
sitting at the top of apple's display is
a 12 megapixel camera but how is the
image quality
not good actually bad
let's take a look here's the apple
studio display in my well-lit home
office
grainy
now look at it compared to the
front-facing camera on the iphone 11 pro
which has the same a13 processor and
camera
even the 14-inch macbook pro and the 5k
lg monitors webcam looked better
same situation in the studio oof
it just consistently produced grainy and
washed out images even in good lighting
an apple spokeswoman told me we
discovered an issue where the system is
not behaving as expected we'll be making
improvements in a future software update
but here's the coolest feature it's
called center stage and as i move around
the webcam moves around and it pans to
wherever i go this is very fun
you get me down here
number three speaker quality
there are six speakers in the display
and boy are they good
now for the spatial audio test where i
play music that we don't have the rights
to so you won't be able to listen to it
yes the a13 chip also enables spatial
audio a virtual surround sound
experience
either way these speakers crushed every
other monitor's built-in speakers in my
side-by-side tests
number four
other things
finally a monitor isn't just a monitor
anymore if you have a laptop it's a
docking station the studio has this one
thunderbolt port capable of fast
charging a laptop and then three other
usbc ports that can be used as a hub for
your other gear so you don't always have
to plug them into your laptop
the 5k lg has a similar selection of
ports
my own 4k lg has a selection of older
ports but you know what both of those
lg's have adjustable stands
the studio display requires you pay an
extra 400 for a height adjustment stand
or you know you could just pull this pro
move
so what do you do well if you don't care
about speaker quality or an attractive
aluminum design save the 300 and get the
5k lg but here's some bad news the lg is
sold out now at various retailers but an
lg spokesman told me that it's still an
active product he expects it to be back
in stock in early april
but honestly i wasn't blown away enough
to buy either of these 5k monitors
maybe that will change with this webcam
software update but right now apple's
perks aren't good enough to make me give
up my trusty 450 lg 4k display which let
me remind you does this
better look next time in monitor madness
apple